نبدا نشرب بهذا الخبر اللافت بشان حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قال عمده موسكو ان
عده مباني في المدينه تعرضت لاضرار طفيفه
نتيجه هجمات بمسيره على العاصمه الروسيه
دون وقوع ضحايا ونقلت وسائل اعلام روسيه
ان شهود عيان تحدثوا عن بقايا مسيرات في
كريسنو
غورسوفا بمقاطعه موسكو
نعم لحد الان المعلومات الوارده ان كانت
عنا عمده مدينه موسكو او حاكم مقاطعه
موسكو او حتى سلطات الطوارئ تتحدث عن
اسقاط الدفاعات الجويه لعدد بناء المسيرات
في في اطراف مدينه موسكو وفي
المقاطعه اي في الضواحي المدينه الحديث
الان يدور حول اصطدام احدى المسيرات باحد
المباني السكنيه على اطراف موسكو دون ان
يوقع ضحايا او قتلى وايضا سقوط
بقايا مسيره تم اسقاطها على احد ايضا
الابنيه في مقاطعه موسكو لا يوجد حديث عن
اصابه المسيرات لاهدافها ولكن توجد صور
تظهر اسقاط الدفاعات الجويه للمسيارات في
تحديدا في مدينتي او محيط مدينتي
اديداسوفا وكريسنال غورس وهي مدن قريبه
جدا من
الروسيه نستطيع ان نقول انها فعليا مرتبطه
بشكل اخر بالعاصمه الروسيه ولكن تحدثنا عن
جغرافيه المكان مياده مع موسكو مدينه
كبيره جدا اذا قارنا في المساحه مدينه
موسكو هي ثلاثه اضعاف تقريبا دوله لبنان
او دوله قطر من حيث المساحه وبالتالي
الاصابات لم تاتي في وسط المدينه تاتي في
اطراف المدينه نحن هنا في وسط المدينه لم
نسمعها شيء ولكن بدون شك هذا الهجوم له
تاثير معنا وانه فعليا الثاني الذي يستهدف
العاصمه الروسيه بعد الهجوم المعروف الذي
استهدف احد قباب الكريم
متوقعا بالنظر الى الهجمات العنيفه التي
ايضا وجهت بمسيارات على العاصمه كييف منذ
امس
نعم متوقع مثل ان حدث الهجوم مياده على
هناك تعزيزات
لنقول تعزيزات في الدفاعات الجويه حتى
منظومات الجي بي اس او الجولونات الروسيه
التي يستخدمها حتى التكاسي
يعانون من مشاكل كبيره كونها خارج فعليا
الخدمه بشكل او باخر بمعنى ان هناك تشويش
بشكل كبير يجري من قبل السلطات الروسيه
على كل
الانظمه بهدف
منع اختراقات من الجرونات والجرونات
المسيرات اصبحت عامل جديد في المعركه
الحديثه اثبتت ربما الحرب في اوكرانيا
والحرب منظمات الدفاع الجوي قد تكون ضعيفه
جدا امام هذه المسيرات سواء انطلقت من
مسافات قريبه يعني عندما نتحدث عن موسكو
نتحدث عن اقرب نقطه يتواجد فيها الجيش
الاوكراني نظريا هي اكثر من 800 كيلو متر
وبالتالي
بمقارنه الدرونات على الاقل التي شاهدناها
في الصور هذه لا يمكن ان تنتقل لهذه
المسافات الطويله وبالتالي يمكن الحديث
الان وهذا ما يتم تداوله هنا كثيرا في
الاوساط ان كانت السياسيه وان كانت
الاعلاميه الروسيه عن اطلاق هذه السيارات
حتى من داخل ربما الاراضي الروسيه وهذا ما
تم اثباته على الاقل في بعض الهجمات
الاخيره التي وقعت في
الهجمه التي تمت بمسيارات على الكرملين
بقيت مساله الهجمات على المياده هي تحت
اشارات الاستفهام كبيره لحد الان لم نعرف
بالضبط كيف تمت هذه الهجمات ولكن تبقى
الامور في اطار التكهنات لان هناك تعتيم
كبير على هذا الهجوم الذي تم على قصر ولكن
دون شكها جمال اليوم هي معطى جديد في هذه
المعركه
يبقى سؤال كيف سيكون الرد الرسل كما ستعمل
موسكو التي تحصلت في الاشهر الاخيره بشكل
كبير ان كانت بمنظومات اس 4
او منظومات بانسر طبعا لا يمكن ان يقوم
صاروخ بانطراز اس 400 تكلفته ملايين
الدولارات بقصر درون يمكن لا يتجاوز سعره
30 او 40,000 دولار وبالتالي هناك تحدي
كبير امام
ربما الدول في المعركه الحديثه فيما يتعلق
بمواجهه
الجديد الذي دخل على المعركه وان كان لم
يكن له تاثير
فيزياء لنقل كبير تاثير تدمير كبير ولكن
بدون شك تاثيره المعنوي
ومهم الان في هذه المواجهه
وفق حاكم مقاطعه موسكو كان الحديث عن ان
دفاعات الجويه الروسيه تتصدى للهجمات من
هذه المسيرات على عده مناطق في المقاطعه
هل نتحدث عن هجوم انتهى تم قصف مبنيين حسب
ايضا التصريحات الرسميه الروسيه ام ان هذه
الهجمات لا زالت مستمره
لحد الان الحديث عننا هجمات انتهت هي
اجابه تقريبا قبل ساعه ونصف من الان لا
يوجد اي هجمات جديده فريقه جزيره يتوجه
الى احد اماكن الهجمات طبعا كما قلت مدينه
كبيره جدا حتى الوصول الحركه فيها معقده
مدينه ضخمه للغايه وبالتالي نحاول الوصول
الى اقرب نقطه يمكن التي تم استهدافها وهي
تم اصابه مبنى سكني امل المناطق الاخرى
التي جرى فيها في ضواحي العاصمه الروسيه
عموما لحد الان الحديث فقط عن مبنانين
سكنيين تعرضا لاصابات طفيفه احدهما باصابه
مباشره من الدرون من المسيره والثاني
نتيجه سقوط اشلاء من المسيره على هذا
المبنى وحسب الصور هناك يعني تضرر في زجاج
المباني على الواجهه ولكن بيوشك كما قلت
ربما في
مضمونها المعنوي اكثر تاثيرا من مضمونه
التدمير طيب نشير فقط مشاهدينا الى ان هذه
الصور التي وصلتنا قبل قليل من العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو تظهر اذن هذا الهجوم
للمسيرات ويبدو استهداف من قبل الدفاعات
الجويه لها واسقاط احدى المسيرات هذه
الصور التي وصلتنا حتى الان حول هذا
الهجوم الذي تعرضت له موسكو زور ايضا في
جزئيه الاضرار كان هناك حديث لعمده موسكو
نقلته نفوستي تحديدا عن وجود ايضا اصابات
بسيطه هل هناك اي تاكيد لذلك
لحد الان طلب عمده موسكو الالتزام
المعلومات رس
ميا كما يجعل العاده هناك كثير من مواقع
التي
تبث اخبارا مختلفه حول الاصابه حتى الان
الطوارئ الروسيه لم تتحدث عن اي اصابات
يعني لنا ان تكون هناك اصابات طفيفه بسبب
ربما الزجاج المتناثر طبعا ممكن كل شيء
ولكن من حجم الاضرار عاقل التي نشاهدها
الان من صوريا هي ليست اضرار كبيره ولكن
هناك
ملفت جدا انه حجم الردود الفعل الامنيه
مياده ان كانت عند هجوم الكرم وعند هجوم
الان ليست بهذه الامور الردود الفعل
الامنيه الكبيره يعني لم نشاهد نحن في
شارع اي تعزيزات امنيه اضافيه او نلاحظ ان
هناك نوع من
[موسيقى]
الرعب او الخوف حتى على الاقل من الصور
التي تصلنا من المكان الحادث هناك رد فعل
طبيعي سيارات اطفاء وبعض الشرطه الموجوده
في عين المكان هذا ايضا يطرح تساؤلات
كبيره فيما يتعلق بالتعزيزات الامنيه التي
لم نشهدها نحن بعد هجوم الكرملين الذي جرى
مطلع الشهر كانت الحياه عاديه جدا في محيط
الكريم بعد ساعات قليله من هذا اليوم هل
ذلك يعكس زوار اذا ان مستوى الخطر بالنسبه
لموسكو فيما يتعلق بهذه الهجمات ليس عاليا
في تقييمها
نقول ان هجمات مؤثره بحجم المسيرات هي
ليست
مسيرات من نوع المتطور او القادر على
تحقيق اعمال تفجيريه كبيره
واضح انها ليست
لم تطلق المسافات بعيده يعني على عكس ما
جرى في الاشهر الماضيه عندما اطلقت
مسيارات بقوات تفجيريه بقوه تفجيريه كبيره
استهدفت منشات نفطيه في جنوب روسيا تحديدا
في شمال القوقاز وقرب الحدود مع اوكرانيا
حجم المسيرات يبدو انها على الاقل من
النظره الاولى وعدها ما تتحدث عنه ايضا
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه هي سيارات صغيره
الحجم نسبيا ذات قوه تفجيريه ليست كبيره
ربما حجم التفجيرات هو نتيجه المضادات
الجويه تاثيرها اكبر من حجم التفجير
للسيارات طبعا هذا كله معطيات اوليه اننا
نستطيع الحكم نحكم فقط من خلال
وارد لحد الان من المعلومات صحيحه في هذا
الشهر ولكن يبقى الاثر المعنوي اذا كما
اشرت ايضا قبل قليل خاصه ان وصول هذه
الهجمات الى موسكو يختلف عندما نتحدث عن
المناطق الحدوديه
بالطبع طبعا تاثير المعنوي هو اكبر عندما
نتحدث نحن يعني للمقارنه موسكو لاول مره
تتعرض فعليا في العصر الحديث الصح التعبير
في القانون بعد ما بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه الى هجوم حتى عندما هاجم هتلر على
موسكو لم يستطيع الوصول الى العاصمه روسيا
وتوقف على بعد
كيلومترات من العاصمه الروسيه كان
يستهدفها عن بعد ولكن عندما تصل
الدرونات الى قلب العاصمه كما جرى في
الكرمله او الى ضواحي العاصمه سكنيه كثافه
سكانيه فيها كبيره في هذه المناطق
المستهدفه الان هي شوارع مهمه ورئيسيه في
العاصمه وان لم تكن في وسط المدينه هي
ايضا مناطق تجاريه مهمه مناطق احياء مهمه
في العاصمه الروسيه بدون شك هذا سيكون له
انعكاسات ان كان على الشارع الذي لحد كبير
فعليا الحرب بعيده عنه بمعنى ان الحرب
موجوده على الاراضي الاوكرانيه لمن يزور
موسكو ويزور المدن الروسيه باستثناء بعض
المناطق الحدوديه لا يشعر وكان هناك حرب
تجري في اوكرانيا يعني ان انا اتكلم
بمصداقيها كامله لكن الان بدا المواطن
الروسي يشعر ان الحرب بدات تصل على ابوابه
في العاصمه الروسيه كما ذكرت ربما من
الناحيه المعنويه له تاثير اكبر هذا
الهجوم من ناحيه التفجيريه